ils sont volontaires pour travailler le
dimanche et veulent le faire savoir le
collectif les bricoleurs du dimanche est
né il y a 6 mois on a créé un collectif
parce qu'on a été attaqué par les
magasins Bricorama qui eux ont été
obligés de fermer par le biais de Force
Ouvrière et donc on voulait justement
montrer que en dehors d'attaquer nos
entreprises nous on vous les montrer
qu'on était volontaire et qu'on voulait
obtenir un décret qui te permettrait de
pouvoir travailler le dimanche comme on
le veut si demain les dimanches ferme
c'est entre 17 et 20% de nos salaires
qu'on va perdre donc c'est pour ça qu'on
se dit aussi le collectif souhaiterait
faire évoluer la législation
actuellement l'ouverture le dimanche
n'est pas autorisée sauf si le magasin
est classé en zone puce zone fortement
commerciale ou sur autorisation
préfectorale une pétition nationale a
été diffusée 200 000 signatures
recueillies et des clients qui se
dimanche les soutenaient le fait que le
dimanche soir rémunéré et double et donc
du coup pour les salariés c'est quand
même en gros avantage et oui c'est de la
demande de travail donc on peut
évidemment pas aller à l'enfant de ça
c'est une bonne idée et il faut
uniformiser les tous les magasins qui
soient ouverts tous le dimanche ou qui
soit tous fermés le dimanche le
collectif lui ne milite que pour
l'ouverture des magasins de bricolage et
uniquement en Île-de-France il a reçu le
soutien d'une dizaine de députés
socialistes pour demander la création
d'une commission parlementaire